le mardi noir c'est l'intitulé de la
mobilisation des élèves du lycée joseph
zobel à rivière salée
c'est l'effet papillon ils répondent à
l'appel des lycéens de métropole
déterminé depuis quelques jours a
bousculé le gouvernement pour qu'il
annule toutes les nouvelles réformes qui
les pénalisent fortement nous en tant
que quand tu y es d'habitants
d'outre-mer on est vraiment à laisser
sur le côté parce que la réforme de
parcours sur la creuse est vraiment les
inégalités entre l'hexagone et de
l'autre merde
il ya des cas concret comme la major du
bac de polynésie qui a été refusé avec
21 28 peut-être 7 de moyenne et elle a
été refusée dans des écoles les écoles
ou a été brûlée à paris donc c'est pas
normal c'est un mouvement que les
glissières ne compte pas lâcher sans
résultat ils veulent fédérer tous les
établissements pour être mieux entendu
les élèves du lycée joseph zobel insiste
sur le côté pacifique de leur démarche
et c'est dans cet esprit qu'ils veulent
aller à la rencontre du recteur
d'académie
dans quelques jours on est vraiment là
pour monter un mouvement généralisé
aujourd'hui c'était au lycée joseph
zobel au lycée des marcs à demain je
l'espère ce sera les autres lycées qui
viendront nous rejoindre
et je l'espère que le recteur pourra
nous aussi nous entendons donc vraiment
le sommes là pour la discussion
nous sommes là pour avancer les lycéens
ont été reçus ce matin par le proviseur
il dit reconnaître la légitimité du
mouvement
ils sont mobilisés jusqu'à ce vendredi
14 mai s'ils n'obtiennent pas
satisfaction
des lycéens de rivière-salée à neuf un
durcissement dès la semaine prochaine